y
[Música]
el parlamento británico y la reina
isabel segunda la jefa de estado del
reino unido- avalaron el acuerdo
comercial con la unión europea para
poner fin al break city a la medianoche
de hoy hora de bruselas
el reino unido- dejará formalmente el
grupo de los 27 tenemos detalles desde
la ciudad de londres
y en el otro lado del canal de la mancha
y expectativa en la europa continental
por el retiro del reino unido- del
bloque comunitario y cómo comenzará a
construirse una nueva relación política
y comercial después de alcanzar un
acuerdo que debe ser ratificado también
por el parlamento europeo a finales de
febrero tenemos más detalles desde parís
y una buena parte de los países de
oceanía y de asia ya han recibido el año
2021 en medio de celebraciones atípicas
por las medidas de bioseguridad
impuestas para mitigar el avance de la
pandemia el mundo cierra el 2020 con más
de 82 millones 800 mil casos de contagio
la américa latina se prepara para
celebrar con estrictas restricciones
muy buenas tardes bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález 31 de diciembre del 2000 20
último día del año gracias por
informarse con nosotros la historia del
presidio a su último capítulo y termina
el periodo de transición y comienza un
nuevo episodio en el que londres y
bruselas deberán tener un entendimiento
bajo nuevas reglas de esta forma se pone
fin a una relación constructiva de 47
años entre ambas partes entre el reino
unido y la unión europea así el reino
unido- estas islas británicas le dicen
adiós a uno de sus socios comerciales
más importantes en términos económicos y
financieros esta soberanía anhelada por
los euroescépticos llega acompañada por
supuesto de nuevas reglas en términos
comerciales trabas burocráticas y altos
costos para las empresas mientras tanto
el mundo entero observa con mucho
cuidado cada paso que da a londres en su
lucha por la soberanía y en su
reposicionamiento a nivel internacional
vamos a conversar con luisa pulido la
corresponsal de france 24 en la capital
británica muy buenas tardes allí en
londres
luisa y a partir del primero de enero
entonces que va a cambiar en la vida del
reino unido y en esa relación con la
unión europea
buenas tardes va a cambiar mucho desde
como los británicos pasan sus vacaciones
en europa hasta las importaciones y las
exportaciones y como las empresas pueden
estar preparadas es cierto no habrá
aduanas ni tarifas pero lo cierto es que
habrá burocracia y papeleo para las
importaciones a partir del primero de
enero de 2021 entra en vigor también un
acuerdo de libre comercio entre este
país y la unión europea que está
avaluado de más de 600 billones de
libras esterlinas un paso bien
importante también el primer ministro ha
dicho que el reino unido- recupera
entonces su independiente de
independencia política económica de su
presupuesto de sus leyes de sus
fronteras y de sus aguas además entra en
vigor un nuevo sistema migratorio la
libre circulación de ciudadanos europeos
se acaba si una persona del continente
quiere venir a trabajar oa estudiar debe
ceñirse a un estricto sistema migratorio
de puntos debe mostrar suficiencia en él
inglés debe demostrar calificaciones
estudios y usted
para la movilidad también cada país
europeo evaluará uno por uno del caso de
los británicos residentes en esos países
luisa el break si le da un gran impulso
a estos movimientos independentistas y
también a los euroescépticos entonces
cómo quedaría el panorama después de que
se lleve a cabo esta salida del reino
unido de la unión europea
escocia es un país del reino unido- que
hace bastantes años estaba gritando por
tener su independencia lo que sucede en
este momento la primera ministra
escocesa nicola sturgeon ha dicho que
una de sus prioridades es convertir ese
camino de la independencia jurídico y
político posible en este momento dado la
gestión de nicolás torsión sobre el
coronavirus de manera independencia y de
manera independiente en escocia hace
pensar que la independencia está ganando
cada vez más posibilidades gracias luisa
por este reporte desde londres la
capital británica y mientras tanto al
otro lado del canal de la mancha en la
europa continental hay expectativa en
torno a cómo será la construcción de esa
relación entre bruselas y londres
también los beneficios y las desventajas
que traerá sobre el futuro del bloque
comunitario desde parís la capital
francesa previamente nuestro periodista
luís miguel cabrera nos daba más
detalles de lo que se está esperando
allí
gran espectativa en francia- a pocas
horas de que se haga efectiva la salida
del reino unido- de la unión europea
tras casi medio siglo de presencia en
este bloque una expectativa que no es
para menos si tenemos en cuenta la
importantísima relación económica que
existe entre ambos países el reino unido
es uno de los destinos principales de
los productos de las industrias
agroalimentarias automotriz espacial y
aeronáuticas de francia y a su vez este
país es el cuarto destino de las
exportaciones del reino unido- hay
cierto alivio debido a esos acuerdos
alcanzados y firmados hace algunas horas
que en teoría van a mitigar el efecto
negativo de él preside- sin embargo se
espera que esa separación tenga un
efecto en el producto interno bruto
francés de 0.1 por ciento para el año
próximo con todo este panorama de fondo
y en medio de una crisis sanitaria
los franceses esperarán 2021 bajo un
toque de queda entre 8 de la noche y 6
de la tarde la mitad de las líneas de
metro cerradas aquí en parís
prohibiciones en todo el territorio
nacional para reunirse en lugares
y también en grupos de más de 6 personas
dentro de su casa en las próximas horas
también el presidente emmanuel macro me
emitirá su tradicional discurso de fin
de año dirigido a los franceses louis
miguel cabrera reportando desde la
ciudad de parís y con muchas
restricciones para mitigar el avance del
coronavirus el mundo comenzó a recibir
el año 2021 con la expectativa puesta en
el fin de esta emergencia sanitario
internacional el mundo termina el año
con más de 82 millones 800 mil casos
confirmados de kobe 19 y cerca de 1.8
millones de víctimas mortales
américa latina se prepara para una
celebración de año nuevo con muchas
restricciones y con un repunte de
contagio alva santana nos cuenta más
sin festejos con restricciones y sin
gente en las calles el fin de año de
2020 será recordado como el más raro en
la memoria
francia no recibirá el 2021 con
celebraciones como quinto país a nivel
mundial en contagios los tradicionales
fuegos artificiales de los campos
elíseos han sido anulados cien mil
policías se encargarán de hacer cumplir
un toque de queda entre las ocho de la
tarde y las seis de la mañana y las
reuniones públicas están prohibidas la
cuna de la nueva variante del virus
reino unido también se enfrenta a duras
medidas sociales y se quedará sin el
espectáculo pirotécnico que la gente
observado desde las orillas del támesis
también alemania suele ser sinónimo de
espectáculo de pirotecnia para despedir
el año pero no esta vez tanto las
reuniones como los espectáculos en
lugares públicos están prohibidos
durante el 31 de diciembre y el 1 de
enero en este duro 2020 existen que yo
creo que no estoy exagerando cuando digo
nunca en los últimos 15 años hemos
pensado que el año viejo había sido tan
pesado como este y nunca a pesar de las
preocupaciones y el escepticismo
hemos esperado tanto y con tanta
esperanza el año nuevo al otro lado del
atlántico la situación no es mejor en
eeuu el primer país del mundo en casos y
número de muertes nueva york ha cerrado
times square y la gente tendrá que
festejar desde sus casas o virtualmente
brasil el tercero en la cola de
contagios tampoco verá desde las orillas
del río de janeiro el clásico despliegue
de fuegos artificiales a medida que el
país sigue registrando un número récord
de muertes la crisis también se extiende
a colombia que se aproxima a los 43 mil
decesos impondrá ley seca y toque de
queda en las principales ciudades del
país para contener el virus méxico a
pesar de ser pionero en vacunación en la
región está desde hace semanas en
semáforo rojo epidemiológico y para fin
de año la economía no esencial
permanecerá cerrada en los principales
estados con esta situación a nivel
global las esperanzas en el año nuevo
están puestas en la aplicación de
vacunas
y varios países ya han recibido el año
kiribati samoa y tonga fueron los
primeros en celebrar la llegada del año
nuevo hace unos minutos también lo hizo
la isla de taiwán en donde los
ciudadanos fueron a apreciar este
espectáculo de pirotecnia en el centro
de taipei la capital taiwanesa bajo
estrictas medidas de bioseguridad con
estas imágenes lo dejamos aquí en este
informativo de france 24 siga con
nuestra programación buenas tablas
[Música]